mais d'abord donc le jour d'après pour
valérie pécresse à son qg de campagne ce
matin au menu du déjeuner c'était soupe
à la grimace jonathan du prises avec
guillaume bertrand
monsieur hortefeux quel est votre
sentiment sur le meeting d'hier
ce matin au qg de valérie pécresse les
ténors sont pressés et quelque peu sur
la défensive est en forme et vous voir
après le meeting dia qui a été très
compliqué partie
prend la forme notamment
leur candidate était censé se relancer
grâce au meeting du zénith hier mais les
critiques ont fusé peu après sa
prestation qualifiée par certains de
naufrage notamment sur la forme des
critiques que valérie pécresse balaie
d'un revers de main écoutez si vous
voulez des beaux parleurs vous en avez
plein dans cette campagne si vous voulez
quelqu'un qui fait je crois qu'il ya pas
qu en bout le président du parti
christian jacob préfère lui aussi voir
le verre à moitié plein
d'abord il y avait une belle salle il y
avait de lire et de l'ambiance
et puis voilà l énergie qu il ya dans
les campagnes électorales au qg de
campagne on préfère donc affiché les
bonnes nouvelles si infime soit elle
comme le soutien de l'ancien premier
ministre edouard balladur que notre
union mail
convaincre les français que sont
c'est un soutien important mais le
malaise en flèche ailée l air autour de
sa référence au grand remplacement
certains l'accusent d'avoir repris la
thèse à son compte pour courtiser
l'électorat d'eric zemmour et de marine
le pen ce qu'elle dément ses lieutenants
montent au créneau pour la soutenir est
ce qui est incroyable c'est le lynchage
médiatique auquel on assiste aujourd'hui
jusqu'à d'ailleurs à renverser la
signification d'un certain nombre de
phrases parlées par exemple sur le
déclassement et et le remplacement sa
phrase de dire qu'il n'ya pas de
fatalité ni pour le grand déclassement
ni pour le grand remplacement nous nous
voulons lutter contre l'islamisme reste
à voir l' influence d'une telle sortie
sur les sondages valérie pécresse marine
le pen et eric zemmour sont actuellement
au coude à coude autour de 15% des
intentions de vote au premier tour
valérie pécresse bonjour tristesse on a
choisi un titre allez volontiers est
volontairement provocateur pour ce débat
vous présente mes invités bérengère
bonté bonsoir vous êtes journaliste
politique vous publiez le sioux c'est
une biographie d'edouard philippe aux
éditions l'archipel et puis signale
aussi votre participation à ce ce mook
la fabrique de la présidentielle 2022
c'est l'acte ii c'est un bonheur à
chaque fois et vous signez un article
sur fabien roussel le écrit quand
l'article au mois de décembre
du pif train de monter dans les sondages
qui casse les codes on sait très bien
accueilli également ils me disent ah
parce qu'ils m'ont soir ses revenus vous
êtes communicante politique à vos côtés
pascal perrineau bonsoir pascal
politologue professeur à sciences po
paris en duplex avec nous gaël sliman
qui est le président cofondateur doxa
bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce plateau
enfin non en duplex une nouvelle fois et
puis matthieu croissandeau qui lui est
bien sur ce plateau bonsoir monsieur
merci merci d'être là comme tous les
lundis les mercredis allez je vais
demander à un petit exercice pour
commencer à un mot ou un adjectif pour
qualifier le meeting de valérie pécresse
hier je commence avec vous bérengère il
a été beaucoup repris mais comme je lé
prononcé hier je veux reprendre c'est
naufrage naufrage c'est un mot qui est
vraiment dure comment vous le justifier
il ya beaucoup de choses à dire sur mes
pensées ils se sont obstinés alors l
envoyer au casse pipe mais moi je
considère fait l'exercice est
complètement raté ça ça ressemble à un
naufrage pascal perrineau vous êtes
peut-être plus positif oui moi je dirais
femmes mais ensuite je m'expliquerai
pourquoi c'est une femme dans un monde
d'hommes que l'on juge avec des critères
qui sont des critères entièrement
construit depuis des décennies par les
hommes et qu'est ce qu'on demande à une
femme en matière politique c'est d'être
un homme comme les autres et là quelque
part valérie pécresse en effet n'a pas
été un homme que les autres elle a
essayé et c'est le tort de son entourage
de l'avoir fait jouer sur ce terrain
alors qu'on connaît valérie pécresse par
exemple quand elle est dans le cadre
plus intime des studios de télévision
quand elle efface un journaliste ou face
à un contradicteur et là elle est très
bien et avec j'allais dire les micros
d'aujourd'hui la sono d'aujourd'hui
c'était pas la peine de la faire jouer
l'homme tonitruant en tapant sur la
poitrine mais on y reviendra évidemment
en détails parce que c'est effectivement
il ya même des accusations de mise ni
dans le temps de dire la tonalité
générale risque notamment des
journalistes ou des commentateurs depuis
depuis hier c'est quoi le mot qui selon
vos raisons je suis assez d'accord avec
ce que vous venez de dire pascal mais
moi j'aurais été tentée par rater
évidemment parce que c'était un exercice
qui était compliqué sur la forme sur le
fond aussi parce que ça crée de la
confusion en tout cas avec cette ligne
très droitière j'aurais tendance à dire
perfectible parce que dans la lignée de
ce que vous venez de dire pascal si elle
arrivait à trouver son style son ton si
elle respectait en effet sa féminité et
sa façon faire elle peut aller beaucoup
plus loin elle peut se faire confiance
en fait il faut que ce soit une femme
qui tape du poing sur la table et qui
disent maintenant c'est moi la bosse je
fais comme je l'entends et on y va comme
ça ils écoutent probablement un petit
peu trop des autres gaël sliman mêmes
questions sur un mot un adjectif pour
résumer et eu peut-être si on va essayer
d'aller un peu plus loin quel impact ce
meeting et peut-être même au-delà du
meeting parce qu'il ya finalement assez
peu de français qui l'ont regardé in
extenso hier les commentaires autour du
mythique quel impact ça peut avoir dans
l'opinion d'après vous
pour les mots je dirais occasions
manquées et je pense que naufragé est
trop sévère et en même temps c'était une
est un exercice qui a été ratée sur la
forme je comprends très bien ce que veut
dire pascal perrineau donc je ne vais
pas faire un teasing spoilé ce qu'il va
à ce qu'il va vous expliquer ensuite
mais je pense qu'effectivement on lui a
fait jouer une partition qui n'était pas
elle un petit peu comme quand on on a
voulu un moment les communicants de
d'alain juppé lui ont expliqué qu' il
était très populaire mais qu'il fallait
avoir la plus sympathique et donc on le
voyait en train de faire des parties de
bingo beer pong on a vu dans votre sujet
edouard balladur edouard balladur
souvenez-vous en 95 faisant prenant le
métro le rer pour montrer qu'il était
proche des gens ce qui crée une forme de
deux de dissonance cognitive de rupture
par rapport à l'image qu'on s'était fait
du personnage et donc là ça a sonné faux
sur la forme mais aussi sur le fond et
je pense que c'est effectivement bien
dommage pour elle mais ça n'est pas fini
je pense qu'on aurait tort de l'enterrer
trop vite mais c'est sûr que c'est une
occasion manquée pour elle bon viendra
sur l'impact dans l'opinion tout à
l'heure la parole d'une première fois
évidemment à mathieu vous étiez pas
forcément d'accord avec tout ce qui se
disait autour de cette chaîne notamment
peut-être sur l'entourage c'est ça
l'idée de lui faire jouer une partition
je pense que quand on est candidat à la
présidence de la république on imprime
sa partition n'y a pas ou alors aussi
une vision encore très masculine des
choses de pouvoir dire que c'est une
candidate donc c'est une marionnette
donc on peut lui faire faire un héros de
claquettes tel qu'on l'a décidé c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe quand on
est candidat qu'on soit homme ou femme
on impose ses codes on impose on impose
son style prenez un exemple ségolène
royal en 2007 que sheikh singer baroque
que certains jugeaient complètement
abracadabrantesque parce qu'elle ne
répondait pas notamment à tous ces codes
très masculin elle faisait des meetings
à sa façon donc le fait qu'on soit un
homme ou une femme mon avis ne change en
rien le marieur
pendant les débats de la primaire et du
congrès on a entendu cette façon de
parler par slogan par formule plus ou
moins réussi parfois creuse moi je pense
pas que ce soit un exercice la prise de
parole en public qui lui qu'il y aille
vraiment elle est plutôt bonne dans la
réponse à nos français les bonnes dents
de la contradiction mais l'espèce
d'allocutions c'est pas quelque chose
qu'il va puis enfin juste jeu
rebondissait sur naufrage parce que moi
je suis assez d'accord lady elle-même
d'une certaine façon dans un splendide
lapsus en disant qu'elle aimait la
france corps et biens au lieu de corps
et âme coors et bien c'est quoi c'est
une expression maritimes ont dit pour
les navires qui disparaissent corzé bien
au fond de l'eau j'ai juste petite
nuance parce que moi je vois je ne
dirais pas que tous les torts sont à
mettre sur le dos de son équipe je pense
que les torts sont partagés et ce qu'on
comprend aujourd'hui quand même c'est
qu'en gros igor
mitrofanoff la plume l'ancienne plume de
françois fillon dont on a beaucoup parlé
avait produit un discours qu'elle a
choisi de réécrire complètement pour
produire ce qu'elle a produit là
l'équipe évidemment était là pour la
protéger probablement et 6,6 à ce sujet
d'un discours un peu plus un peu décousu
à grand chose qui parle dans tous les
sens qui manque de rythme qui
quitteraient h et enfin autre chose
c'est qu'il ya une concurrence très rude
sur des orateurs qui sont beaucoup plus
radicaux qui n'hésite pas à balancer des
mots enfin je transfère en particulier
eric zemmour qui va très très loin qui
en a rien à faire en fait de ce qu'on
pense et ce qu'on peut ce qui peut
provoquer et elle elle est sur des
propos beaucoup plus mesurée des mesures
finalement si on regarde tout ce qu'elle
a dit qu'ils étaient un peu décousu
parce que ça aide en est tous des
connaissances y avait pas de ligne
directrice et finalement ce qu'on
retient c'est qu'elle a pas dit non
contre le grand emplacement mais sinon
si on regarde c'est assez pragmatique
c'est une approche c'est ce qu'elle
disait au départ c'est une femme dû
faire c'est à dire que c'est une
approche pragmatique comme dans son
bilan du conseil régional c'est à dire
qu'à la vancelle fait et ça c'est pas du
tout vendeur on est dans une campagne
express ou c'est le mot qui compte c'est
la provocation c'est la surenchère des
propos radicaux elle n'est pas du temps
du tout là dedans en fait la question
c'est comment mettre en valeur des
propos qui sont un peu plus nuancé un
peu plus pratique un peu probablement il
ya une voie mais elle n'a pas encore
trouvé alors je suis une faisons
effectivement c'est l'argument qu'elle a
employé ce matin c'était sur sur rtl
pour a justifié on va dire les talents
oratoires un peu délaissé hier vous
voulez des orateurs
il y en a plein dans la campagne moi je
suis une fâcheuse et c'est vrai que je
suis plus à l'aise dans le dialogue
direct avec les français peut-être plus
à l'est sur ce plateau avec vous mais le
sujet aujourd'hui
c'est qu'est ce qu'on veut pour la
france est ce qu'on veut des beaux
parleurs ça on en a eu depuis dix ans et
on en aura encore ou est ce qu'on veut
vraiment quelqu'un qui va faire qui va
restaurer l'autorité qui va restaurer
nos services publics abîmé qui va
redonner de la liberté aux français tu
as revaloriser le travail c'est ça la
question alors moi j'entends cet
argument pascal perrineau mais quand
même le talent oratoire en politique
c'est incontournable à base de la base
du métier enfin la base du métier je ne
sais pas si vous avez écouté à plusieurs
reprises celle qui avait été saisie en
pouvoir madame merkel connaissait les
discours de madame merkel s'était
traduit
simplement madame merkel elle exerçait
ses talents qui sont réelles dans un
système parlementaire où il n'y avait
pas d'élections présidentielle
et où les canons peut-être du beau
discours et ces sondes et l'allemagne
est peut-être un peu plus avancés que
nous en la matière parce que ils ont
aussi un personnel politique qui est un
peu plus féminisé que nous vous rendez
compte à par edith cresson jamais une
femme première ministre jamais bien sûr
présidente de la république donc on a
j'allais dire on fait une course se
présidentielle avec handicap un cri a du
travail à faire
et en effet valérie pécresse on le voit
d'ailleurs là dans le studio de rtl
quand il s'agit d'être avec des gens
autour de la table elle est beaucoup
plus elle même elle ne surjoue pas elle
ne donne pas cette impression en effet
parfois d'être un peu à côté oui là que
tu as un sincère parce que c'est un peu
ce qui est lié à la perception du du
meeting hier et sa faune quand même
c'est un certain handicap potentiel pour
les joueurs ni en tout cas va falloir
qu'elle nomme rapidement le pardon je
vous redonner la parole mais dans ce que
vous dites il ya quand même
peut-être un soupçon de misogynie ou en
tout cas vous me disiez un biais lié à
notre un autre habitude à notre histoire
politique alors c'est ce que disaient
aussi à la main que ce matin il était
sur france inter on écoute une des
raisons pour laquelle je souhaite
qu'elle soit élue je pense que ça ferait
du bien à ce pays dabo d'élire une femme
ce qui n'est quand même pas arrivé y'a
pas une femme vous pouvoir depuis anne
d'autriche à ya quand même une petite
musique dans la manière de la critique
et dont on ne m'enlèvera pas l'idée
qu'elle ne serait pas exactement la même
à l'égard d'un homme ce que c'est et
misogyne hier les réflexions sur la
dianétique
insupportable de s'en prendre à savoir
je dirais emmanuel macron s'est envolé
dans les aigus ça n'empêche pas de
présider la france donc je trouve si
vous voulez que deux à cet égard même
dans les milieux qui sont les nôtres qui
sont des milieux de gens qui ont quand
même beaucoup de diplômés autres ya
encore un petit fond de sauce misogyne
qui m'impressionne beaucoup alain minc
n'est pas épidémiologistes mais je
rappelle que le masque ça se porte
vous n'êtes pas du tout d'accord sur le
sujet car dieu sait que je pète suspecté
de sexisme misogynie que c'est un sujet
je met souvent en avant mais en
l'occurrence quand on est mauvais on est
mauvais et je je je trouve que heavy
alors pour le coup là où je suis
d'accord avec un hamac c'est
effectivement la vois je vois pas
pourquoi une voix de femme ne
fonctionnerait pas en meeting mais c'est
encore une fois c'est pas ça le sujet
moi j'ai réécouté par exemple des
meeting de martine aubry cet après midi
passant son temps comme on peut martine
aubry
encore la firme eating et quelques mois
pour avec anne hidalgo elle n'est pas là
en train d'essayer d'avoir une voix
posée elle elle est dans le ton de
martine aubry elle parle anne hidalgo
avec des petits sourires elle ne force
pas la voie et elle fait du martine
aubry c'est juste ça le sujet pourquoi
on a essayé effectivement d'en faire un
candidat masculin tout court un candidat
de la droite ou dans ces grands meetings
mais les drapeaux bleu blanc rouge ou ou
et où on déclame dans une grande salle
c'est ça le sujet - une jeune femme moi
je suis quand même un peu comme un la
main que j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une
petite musique quand même quand on
critique ses vêtements en disant c'est
pas présidentiable d'avoir un petit tee
shirts et pas assez je sais pas il ya
quelque chose quand même qui est pas
tout à fait nette peut-être pas
complètement mais il ya quand même
quelque chose d'une de leurs d'une
musique je suis pas sûr que toute la
famille politique aurait été aussi
acharnée si ça avait été un homme il me
semble mais bon après peut-être que je
deviens une féministe acharnée peut-être
que mon avis et plus + 6 objectifs après
sur anglet la merkel je crois qu'elle
avait quelque chose que valérie pécresse
n'a pas encore c'est l'autorité elle à
une autorité et souvenez-vous quand elle
avait aussi quand elle s'est excusée
c'était pour les locaux vides la crise
covin c'est quand même une espèce de
sublimation en fait de cette figure
politique qui arrive à dire même jusque
là valérie pécresse à la pas encore
cette autorité elles n'arrivent pas à
l'incarner moi je me suis dit quel sont
les figures parce qu'en effet quand même
même si on n'est pas féministe les
figures femmes politiques il y en a pas
beaucoup mais quelles sont elles alors
il ya christiane taubira très bonne
oratrice vous avez parlé de ma marine le
pen dans son style et dans un style
beaucoup plus serein calme oui mais il y
en a pas tant que ça et c'est là où je
rejoins pascal c'est à dire que les
codes qu'on a des hommes politiques pour
l'instant c'est plutôt masculin il faut
se réinventer sur des figures elle parle
aussi de simone veil pourquoi pas suivre
ça parce que je veux dire c'est que
l'imaginaire hommes et femmes politiques
il est plutôt centré sur la virilité
j'avais sur le côté masculin jamais
envie de m'endormir un de mes propres
discours
pas de faire ennuyer forman formation et
la merkel par exemple j'ai
assumé des hésitations ayant assumé des
silences assumer instauré son rythme et
son ton à soi même et pas vouloir faire
en effet viril ou autre chose que ce
qu'on est gaël sliman est ce qu'on a
déjà un
un peu de grain à moudre pour évaluer
l'impact de cette journée globalement
ratée et des critiques et des jugements
négatifs sur sur ce meeting dans
l'opinion
non bien sûr que non c'est trop tôt en
revanche on l'aura très bientôt et il
est probable que ça aura un effet
négatif sur sur les intentions de vote
et sur la cote globale de valérie
pécresse pas forcément parce que tout le
monde aura celui qui sait cette
intervention mais parce que la plupart
des déchus des électeurs se fonde aussi
sur les commentaires qu'ils peuvent lire
entendre voir à ce sujet et parce qu'il
ya une concurrence une compétition
acharnée entre valérie pécresse et
plusieurs adversaires l'électorat qui
envisage de voter aujourd'hui pour
valérie pécresse hésite pour une part
avec emmanuel marc ou pour une part avec
gérer les émouvoir marine le pen donc
c'est pour ça que je parlais d'occasions
manquées tout à l'heure elle avait une
occasion de creuser l'écart avec eric
zemmour et de prendre l'ascendant sur
marine le pen qui est repassé devant
elle dans l'ue dans les intentions de
vote au premier tour de la
présidentielle et il s'en doute at elle
raté cette occasion même si ça n'est pas
définitif je profite juste un instant
pour y est je suis absolument pas
d'accord avec ce qui est dit sur la
misogynie c'est quelque chose qui est
systématiquement utilisée et qui agace à
mal les gens qui est systématiquement
utilisée
lorsque des femmes politiques sont
jugées mauvaises souvent parce qu'elles
le sont vraiment
c était le cas notamment de ségolène
royal dans sa campagne où il ya eu
plusieurs accidents industriels lors des
des propos qu'elle a pu tenir ça a été
le cas pour et c'est encore le cas pour
anne hidalgo aujourd'hui et on a et je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec bérengère
monde bérengère banque pendant des
femmes politiques qui imprime quelque
chose dans des discours et je pensais
moi aussi à martine aubry et je suis
étonné d'ailleurs de voir que donc on
occulte marine le pen qui arrive à
marquer des points à sa manière dans ce
sens'' cours et qui je le rappelle est
une femme en revanche je suis je voyais
bien où je voulais en tire pascal
perrineau on pourra voir si on
l'entendra sujet quand il disait qu'elle
était femmes et en l'occurrence c'est ce
que je voulais dire aussi sur le fait qu
elle est dans une posture sérieuse
rigoureuse j'ai donné l'exemple tout à
l'heure d'alain juppé ou d'edouard
balladur on aurait pu parler lionel
jospin aussi pas forcément sexy
médiatiquement pas forcément emballant
dans le discours mais qui marquent des
points qui marque des points dans
l'opinion parce qu'il donne une
impression de sérieux et de compétence
aux recettes plutôt un atout qu'avait et
cas encore valérie pécresse ce qui fait
qu'elle n'a pas besoin de vouloir fendre
l'armure est sûr jouer la proximité
l'affection l'amour est là elle a
utilisé pas mal de vocables qui relèvent
de ce champ lexical là et je pense que
là elle se trompe et c'est ce que je
voulais bien moi je dis qu'elle est sans
doute été mal conseillé n'est ce pas le
problème que ce soit une femme en
l'occurrence juppé avait avait lui aussi
une mauvais conseils en communication de
ce point de vue là il faut qu'elle soit
elle-même et qu'elle assume d'être
sérieuse quitte à être triste le terme
un petit côté angela merkel on est
heureux on y reviendra dessus là la
question après ce meeting c est ce qu
elle fait encore peur à ses concurrents
alors je suis la femme à abattre ouais
mais valérie pécresse s'était pas il ya
très longtemps c'était il y ait un à la
une du journal du dimanche et
aujourd'hui on se demande également si
ssu pas d'abord tiré une balle dans le
pied autrement dit s'il n'est pas en
train de s'abattre elle même je
caricature mais depuis quelques semaines
et davantage encore depuis sa prestation
d'hier en fait et inquiète davantage ses
propres troupes que ses adversaires et
ça c'est nouveau parce que quand on se
souvient du contraste enfin de
l'emballement vous avez eue au monde sa
désignation à l'époque valérie pécresse
est tel que personne n'avait vu venir
son profil en inquiéter plus d'un dans
la majorité elle était une femme jeune
avec un cv un parcours politique sans
taj capable de river or de rivaliser
avec emmanuel macron la fois sur la
sécurité sur l'économie mais aussi sur
le côté réforme sur le côté modernité et
même du côté d'eric zemmour pour le coup
on pensait à l'époque pouvoir surfer sur
les divisions de la primaire et est
accroché tous les déçus du scientisme et
pas de pop elle avait réussi à
rassembler sa famille bref elle
impressionnait tout le monde contre
toute attente et des sondages faut le
rappeler quand même la donne est
qualifié pour le second tour et même
certains sondages vainqueur face à face
à emmanuel macron alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé mais pour moi la commis
plusieurs erreurs la première cdapp
d'abord d'aller un peu vite en besogne
en voulant installer à tout prix un duel
avec emmanuel macron comme si le premier
tour n'était qu'une formalité sur le
terrain d'à présidentialité pour le coup
il n'y a pas de match comme tous les
présidents en exercice pas le fait que
ce soit mais macron mais il a un coup
d'avancé parce qu'il est président et un
membre de l'équipe de valérie pécresse
réalisé la semaine dernière c'est
compliqué c'est vrai quand on voit à
moscou avec poutine c'est compliqué de
rivaliser sur ce terrain là après par
ailleurs le refus des manuels macron de
descendre dans l'arène des baisses c'est
ici c'est comme si vous essayez de boxer
ou de jouer au ping pong tout seul c'est
plus compliqué et puis la seconde erreur
à mon avis ça a été du coup de négliger
ses adversaires de premier tour à
commencer par eric zemmour parce que on
sait voit bien qu'ils occupent une
partie du même terrain lui se gêne pas
pour l'attaqué ils ne ferment à longueur
et meetings il le fait faire sur les
réseaux sociaux par toute son armada
hier elle ne l'a pas cité une fois et
qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle se contente
de donner l'impression de lui emboîter
le pas sur ses idées plutôt que de faire
valoir sa différence à l éco n'y pas les
états unis elle et elle les reprend un
petit peu à son compte qu est ce qu a
dit hier la fameuse question du grand
remplacement même le terme de
l'adversaire qu'elle reprend et parle de
français de papier et parle de zone de
non france bref elle paraît aujourd'hui
à la remorque ce que s'est d'ailleurs
pas privé de souligner eric zemmour lui
même invité au 20 heures de tf1 hier
soir en dix ans après même valérie
pécresse reprend les mots et puis enfin
la troisième erreur on en a un petit peu
parlé moi je suis petite nuance à gaël
sliman c'est elle a cru qu'un programme
pouvait tenir lieu de laisser passer
pour l'elysée et sa démesure elle en a
c'est vrai que c'est sérieux c'est vrai
qu'elle les assume elle les 10 mais je
pense que pour le reste c'est à dire le
récit la vision la dimension personnelle
là on n'y est pas c'est quand même lancé
en juillet dernier valérie pécresse et
les français qui la connaissent toujours
pas très bien ne semble pas bien avoir
compris ce qu'il apportait alors elle
multiplie les références y avait eu
droit à cette chère merkel chirac simone
veil sarkozy fillon aujourd'hui balladur
ce qui est marrant pour une chirac est
de poser avec eux et balladur quand même
mais ce n'est ni dropping ça dit
toujours rien sur ce qu'elle est elle
qui l est et ce qu'elle veut cette
problème d'incarnation avait dit rachida
dati ya quinze jours
inexistence à a cruellement lâché
nicolas sarkozy la semaine dernière dans
le figaro voilà il reste une semaine
pour essayer de corriger tout ça me
paraît un peu court alors inexistant
c'était des propos proches rapporte des
propos rapportés par nicolas sans que
deux voies la carnation pascal perrineau
est ce que vous êtes en partie ou
d'accords ou au contraire vous mettez
des bémols sur la critique ou l'analyse
de m l'incarnation dans une démocratie
présidentielle c'est important a
expliqué le contraire parce que c'est
l'élection d'un homme est peut-être un
jour d'une femme mais la manière d'un
carnet est en train de changer c'est
vrai que l'incarnation à la de gaulle
l'incarnation à la giscard l'incarnation
à la mitterrand était au fond assez
proche d'une incarnation à la de gaulle
c'était deux frères ennemis qui
s'inspirait beaucoup de là de l'autre
tout ça à mon avis comment ça appartient
appartenir au passé et on est rentrés
dans l'ère de président et c'est pas
c'est pas stigmatisant deux présidents
plus ordinaire
on l'a vu apparaître avec chirac et on
l'a vue d'une manière caricaturale avec
sarkozy avec françois hollande
de manière très claire et il y a eu sept
tentatives
la tentative de revenir à l'esprit des
origines à une incarnation à l'ancienne
qui est celle du président jupitérien
emmanuel macron et on s'aperçoit que
jupiter a du mal à occuper complètement
parce que ça appartient à une autre
époque cette présidence entièrement
verticale qu'incarnait très bien le
fondateur des institutions donc je crois
qu'il ya place aujourd'hui pour d'autres
types d'incarnation c'est ce que je
cherchais confusément sarkozy
confusément et très maladroitement
françois hollande il ya une parenthèse
macron mais je crois que le maquereau à
venir sera forcément va remiser un peu
l'aspect jupitérien même si son
tempérament fait que voilà il est
complètement fasciné certainement par ce
modèle jupitérien et là je crois qu'une
femme a beaucoup pas jouer parce que les
figures d'autorité aujourd'hui dans
certains secteurs sont autant féminines
que masculines
je le regarde moi dans le domaine par
exemple de l'université où il y a plus
de femmes aujourd'hui que d'hommes on
voit bien des figures d'autorité mais
extrêmement différente des figures
masculines
apparaître et donc la féminité est
intéressante parce que ça peut être un
symbole de modernité
de fait ce que disait tout à l'heure à
la mac je suis assez d'accord avec lui
un épousé son temps et donc faire vivre
à la tête du système de la vème
république une autre manière de gérer
les femmes et les hommes alors
j'aimerais qu'on vienne peut-être un peu
plus sur le fond sur la ligne politique
de valérie pécresse estime jourdain peut
nous rejoindrons soir steve évidemment
dans son discours il ya une formule qui
a retenu l'attention le grand
remplacement a peut-être commencé par
rappeler de quoi il s'agit c'est une
formule complotistes il faut lire
xénophobe qui postule la chose suivante
des élites mondialisées font tout et le
font volontairement ce important pour
faciliter la colonisation arabo
musulmane de l'europe tous entre
guillemets évidemment c'est une théorie
qui a inspiré les attentats de christ
church en nouvelle-zélande mais aussi
les manifestations de charlottesville
aux états unis elle a été popularisée
par l'écrivain renaud camus diffusé par
eric zemmour est donc et donc vous
l'évoquez tout à l'heure évoquée hier en
meeting électoral par valérie pécresse
écoutez là dans dix ans serons nous
encore la septième puissance du monde
serons nous encore une nation souveraine
ou un auxiliaire des états unis un
comptoir de la chine seront nourries
nations unies ou une nation éclaté
face à ces questions vitales pas de
fatalité ni aux grandes et classement ni
au grand remplacement est évidemment à
la suite de l'emploi de ces mots valérie
pécresse a subi des critiques à gauche
mais aussi à droite louis dans son
entourage certes on était un peu
abasourdi surpris en tout cas de voir
valérie pécresse reprendre à son compte
les mots d'eric zemmour ce matin donc
sur rtl elle s'en est expliquée écoutez
la cette phrase que j'ai prononcé c'est
une phrase que j'ai prononcé dix fois et
tous les commentateurs qui la reprennent
ont des mémoires du bigorneau la phrase
c'est je ne me résigne ni aux grandes et
classement ni aux grands emplacements ça
veut dire je ne me résigne pas
ajustement aux théories d'eric zemmour
et aux théories de l'extrême droite
parce que je sais qu'une autre voie est
possible
voilà une autre modeste bilan nous on a
donc vérifier effectivement valérie
pécresse a déjà évoqué le grand
remplacement l'afld à plusieurs reprises
ce n'est par exemple au mois de novembre
sur le plateau de lci lors d'un débat
pour le congrès elle est réputée la
déteste cette expression parce qu'elle
donne le sentiment que tout est foutu
elle donne le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui
on peut s'asseoir et puis il ne se
passera rien moi c'est pas ma vision de
la politique ma vision la politique
c'est une vision extrêmement
volontariste il faut avoir le courage de
dire il faut avoir la volonté de faire
là valérie pécresse elle déteste cette
expression est la rejette effectivement
mais elle ne réfute pas pour autant
explicitement clairement fermement cette
théorie ce qu'est ce qui se présente
comme une théorie elle valérie précresse
elle préfère parler de non france la non
france est selon elle ces zones où l'on
a concentré les difficultés sociales et
les populations immigrées thomas merci
steve pour pour toutes ces explications
alors effectivement cette d'abord
comment vous analysez je vais commencer
peut-être avec vous me lisez pas ce qui
commence à analyser la phrase valérie
pécresse hier mais ça crée énormément de
doutes puisque
dans dans sa phrase on al'impression
vraiment quelle qu'elle est en phase
avec cette théorie du grand remplacement
est donc ce matin elle expliqué que c
est l inverse et que personne n'avait
compris je pense qu'elle voit là elle
joue sur cette ambiguïté pour satisfaire
à la fois la frange eric ciotti on va
dire qu'ils étaient pas mal au devant de
la scène dans leurs primaires donc elle
est obligée de cocher cette case là et
qui fâchent en même temps le reste de la
famille moi je pense qu'elle a joué sur
ça est ce que ça peut être gagnant comme
vous l'avez dit c'est eric zemmour qui
est à la manoeuvre là dessus il aura
toujours des mots plus forts il aura
toujours des explications plus fort plus
provocatrice s'en fiche complètement
c'est ça sa ligne depuis le début qu'est
ce qu'elle va gagner à jouer sur cette
ligne là est ce qu'elle peut jouer
on voit toujours préféré l'original que
ce soit chez marine le pen qui est un
petit peu plus modérées sur ça mais qui
vend quand même ça en fonte ou chez eric
zemmour j'ai l'impression que cette
stratégie elle est pas très gagnante
encore une fois c'est une question aussi
taper sur le poing sur la table et de
dire ben voila j'ai fait l'union au
moment de la primaire est ce que je peux
avoir ma ligne et pas forcément coché
toutes les cases des uns et des autres
je vous voyais indiqué pascal perrineau
pour vous il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté dans
le jeu l'écran sera je crois qu'il y a
une grande continuité par rapport à ce
qu'elle a dit elle ne se résignent pas à
ces processus qui sont qualifiés par
eric zemmour email ce remplacement ou de
grands déclassement
si lui
c'est la même chose qu'un moment dans
son discours vous ne la voyez défendre
la notion de grand remplacement ce qui
ne le permet pas de fatalité au bon
emplacement on peut comprendre que
illettrisme et puis il ya des choses à
faire pour l'empêcher
j'oublie membres de la phrase c'est le
grand des classements mais ça c'est ce
qu'elle dénonce elle dit aujourd'hui
nous assistons à un grand des
classements avec monaco donc on peut pas
être voilà il ne se résigne pas quelque
chose auquel elle croît dans le premier
membre de sa phrase et elle ne se
résignent pas à quelques jours elle ne
croit pas dans le surnom de sa phrase
c'est un match comme ça il faut revenir
à la forme parfois on dit que c'est
anecdotique mais si pour comment vous
expliquez que ce matin on comprend
effectivement autres on comprend très
bien ce qu'elle dit discale
manifestement pense et qu'on comprend en
outre choisi hier ya quand même et cette
phrase remplacement n'est pas n'est pas
la seule phrase c'est très étonnant à la
fin de son discours hier elle a cette
formule dit les extrémistes vous mentent
ne laissez jamais le venin et la
nostalgie l'emporter mais alors pourquoi
le grand remplacement pourquoi la nation
se fissure en silence pourquoi marianne
n'est pas une femme voilée pourquoi
cette tonalité qu'il fallait quand même
qu'ils valident quand même deux choses
qui arrivent et que le discours est
placé le curseur à mon avis d'ailleurs
beaucoup trop à droite c'est une réalité
parce que elle fit une campagne de
premier tour on a dû lui expliquer que
l'essentiel c'était de récupérer des
électeurs lepénistes
ouzemour east et ça je crois que au
contraire elle doit tenir les deux bouts
de la chaîne puisqu'il y a autant sinon
plus d'électeurs qui sont passés vers
emmanuel macron et que donc elle doit
s'adresser et doit s'adresser aux deux
ce qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas une
tâche l'image facile mais je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse lui faire le procès
qu'elle prend à son compte la théorie du
grand remplacement elle est il ya
quelques éléments nos au début
d'ailleurs enfin quelques phrases avant
sur un véritable enjeu de cette élection
présidentielle nations unies dit elle ou
nation éclaté éclaté pourquoi éclaté par
le déclassement ce qu'on appelle la
fracture sociale et là tu es par le jeu
des communautés 1 et ceux qui
considèrent en effet que la france de
l'avenir c'est une france des
communautés plus qu une france unie dans
une communauté nationale et une seule
communauté là il ya un vrai enjeu et
c'est au fond ce qu'elle cherche à
décliner de phrases plus loin alors il y
avait quelqu'un que c'était pardon
interrompue c'était intéressant de
l'écouter ce matin sur bfm tv c'est eric
ciotti très satisfait après discours
d'hier
je me suis retrouvée totalement dans le
discours de valérie pécresse est
important j'ai porté ligne au congrès
qui a obtenu 40 % des suffrages au
second tour et cette ligne elle était
fortement exprimée représenter un carnet
hier donc sur le fond de ce discours est
là et quand même l'essentiel il faut pas
oublier qu effectivement c'est eric
ciotti qui est arrivé en tête au premier
tour du congrès gaël sliman moi ce que
j'ai un peu de mal à comprendre si on
considère c'est un peu l'analyse que je
fais que celle aline ciotti qui sert
finalement de fil rouge à son discours
hier parce que vous disiez il était un
peu décousu mais malgré tout elle
revenait toujours à des arguments qui
était plutôt sur cette ligne à mon avis
ou en tout cas les plus puissants
c'était cela gaël sliman cette ligne là
pour l'instant elles ne marchent pas ou
en tout cas pas suffisamment pour
qu'elle se détache dans l'est dans les
enquêtes d'opinion donc pourquoi rester
sur cette ligne-là f1 c'est un mystère
je ne peux pas répondre la deuxième
question parce que je pense que c'est
une folie et une erreur de mener une
campagne sur une ligne ciotti n'slash
zemmour est d'essayer de séduire ou de
récupérer un électorat tenté par le vote
et moore ou par le vote le pen en tenant
un discours sur le fond qui empruntait
ce vocable là pour une fois je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec pascal
perrineau parce que moi je comme comme
les uns et les autres autour du plateau
j'entends quand même une grosse nuance
dans ce que dit valérie pécresse quand
elle parle de grand remplacement par
rapport à la façon dont elle en parlait
dans les débats dans les médecines
précédent j'entends qu'elle veut
emprunter à cette théorie et je
comprends comme vous thomas que quand on
dit il n'ya pas de fatalité ou je ne me
résous pas à ça veut dire que ce grand
remplacement sera en marche et puis de
toute façon elle emploie le mot de
l'adversaire et je crois que c'était une
isabelle ski qui en experte en
communication le disait fort justement
quand on commence à jouer et à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de
l'adversaire on préfère toujours
l'original à la copie et on sait que ça
ne marchera pas et pascal perrineau le
disais je le rappelle quand même mais
une bonne partie des électeurs qui
s'apprête à voter macron cette fois ci
qui sont des électeurs issus de la
droite donc pour moi la stratégie
consistant à essayer de tenir un
discours
ciotti est ce qu ou 12 mg ou rien pour
garder les électeurs les plus
conservateurs me semble doublement
dangereuse alors qu'il y à beaucoup de
gens de droite et d'extrême droite qui
détestent emmanuel macron donc le simple
fait de ne pas être emmanuel macron mais
d'être elle même valérie pécresse
pourrait suffire à lui sécurisé cet
électorat là donc je pense que là il ya
une erreur encore une fois qui est
fréquente mais qui consiste à vouloir
jouer finalement le match à l'extérieur
sur le terrain de l'adversaire matthieu
croissandeau est-ce que c'est pas là
l'une des explications du malaise qu'on
peut ressentir je parlais de la
sincérité tout à l'heure en tout cas
c'est l'un des procès qu'on peut faire à
tort ou à raison à l'ats valérie
pécresse parce que elle se retrouve à
assumer une ligne qui n'est pas tout à
fait confiant dans son histoire
politique
oui mais ce qui est toujours le cas des
candidats jouent avec incomplète autre
exemple sur un autre sujet françois
hollande en 2012 doit affronter la
concurrence gardien qui s'appelle jean
luc mélenchon et qui g qui grimpe grimpe
et va au bourget et qu'est-ce qui fait
il déclare que son ennemi c'est la
finance et qui va faire la taxe à 75% il
sait dining qui est beaucoup plus à
gauche que ce que lui et profondément
que son adn or il se trouve que la taxe
soit retoquée et que voilà il mènera une
politique de l'offre après avoir fait
croire qu'il mènerait une politique la
demande mais en campagne électorale vous
avez ce que vous pensez vous avez votre
adn politique ce que vous êtes et puis
vous avez aussi le contexte qui joue ni
dans l'autre dans le contexte tout là
toute l'habileté tout le tout la science
infuse voilà c'est de pouvoir s'adapter
sans se renier sens trahi oui mais et là
on voit bien qu'elle est écartelé
valérie pécresse que ce trouble
profondément là il est en train de se
séparer à mes yeux de toute l'image
qu'elle pouvait incarner qui était celle
de la modernité celle de miel et
réformer la france celle qui hier ce
qu'on a entendu même d'un point de vue
économique c'est on va baisser les
impôts et y lutter contre cette
administration derrière laquelle
chaque fois il ya un kafka qui ce qui
qui sommeille disait telle foi des
arguments qu'on entend à droite qui sont
éculés et je fais le lien avec ce que
vous disiez sur emmanuel macron il est
jupitérien depuis qu'il est président
mais il n'a pas fait du tout nos
campagnes jupitérienne en 2017 il
incarnait autre chose des carnets à tort
ou à raison
de fraîcheur tels que quelque chose
qu'elle ait débloqué la france quelque
chose qui a bougé un peu comme sarkozy
déferlante cette voie là elle pourrait
jouer ses cartes là et là d'une certaine
façon elle va une frange extrême de son
parti et de son électorat qui à mon avis
va lui faire perdre mais tout ce qu'il
faut dire que c'est quand même compliqué
parce que dans ce paysage droite extrême
droite c'est tout et tout est un peu
pris en fait grand remplacement ses prix
pouvoir d'achat ces prix en ce moment
par marine le pen et même le
rassemblement de cette france éclaté
marine le pen est là dessus un petit peu
aidé par eric zemmour qu'il a un petit
peu orienté vers ça puisque lui est
parti sur les fondamentaux régalien donc
marine le pen a occupé ces cd mais si on
va lui faire un point lui dire vous est
la copie conforme des manuels mcg moi je
pense qu'il ya en effet quelque chose à
trouver de l'ordre de cette espèce dans
gala merkel ou même j'irai une figure
comme bruno le maire qui était pas très
charismatique et qui en faisant en étant
pragmatique ministre de l'économie
finalement d espèce de figure comme ça
dont on n'a pas l'habitude parce que
c'est c'est pas les codes qu'on a en ce
moment qui sont plutôt des codes
vaillant dynamique mais quelque chose
d'un petit peu plus sérieux pragmatique
peut-être moderne en effet avec cette
image de femme qui pourrait diriger il
ya tout à construire il ya un récit à
construire autour de ça sûrement je vais
je vous donne la parole mais je voudrais
juste qu'on regarde l'inde et des
éléments du jour sont ces photos photos
et des images avec l'ancien premier
ministre edouard balladur c'était une
sorte de je sais pas de contre-feux
médiatiques on peut l'appeler comme ça
dans dans cette journée où nous les
images s'agissait aussi de contrer cette
espèce de de bruit
généraliser assez négatif pour valérie
pécresse comment vous analysez ces
images bérangère et puis vous pourrez
rajouter ce que vivre en ville maudite
et je sais pas parce que les 92 13 ans
mais ça reste c'est un premier ministre
était une des figures et finalement à
droite et à défaut pour l'instant dans
ton nicolas sarkozy à ses côtés je pense
qu'elle est assez heureuse d'avoir ce
premier ministre qui disait encore hier
sous la plume de catherine et dans le
jdd que qui ne voulaient pas s'engager
je pense que edouard balladur qui on l'a
dit tout à l'heure quelqu'un lui dit
tout à l'heure qui était quand même pas
non plus un grand orateur qui a eu des
meetings compliqué en 95 ils se sont
d'ailleurs à l'époque vraiment creuser
le ciboulot pour essayer de trouver des
façons dans des meetings plus petit il
ya déjà des images on voit deux mains
sur les tables mais ils ont essayé de
lui faire faire des choses pas forcément
toujours bien inspiré mais en tout cas
il avait cherché et peut-être que
d'avoir vu valérie pécresse en
difficulté va je me disais ça moi
aujourd'hui en le voyant à courant alors
que yahia 24 heures il disait qu'il
hésite et qui est ce qui est sûr c'est
que sa famille pour une politique pour l
aider plutôt que la nationale il a
critiqué les derniers mois c'est quand
même une
chose qu'on n'a pas évoqué ce etc ou et
programmes de l air qu a fait l air
depuis un an quand on l'a beaucoup dit
sur la gauche ces derniers mois le ps
programme voilà mais qu'a fait la droite
à part à part de lentilles macro et un
peu sécurité immigration moi franchement
je ne sais pas où est le programme alors
certes il faut qu'elle incarne ça c'est
valérie pécresse la candidate mais le
cactus quand même ce serait bien qu'ils
ont une fenêtre qu'elle puisse en
profiter merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je leur
montre ce mook l'acte 2 2022 la fabrique
de la présidentielle et votre article
sur fabien roussel à lire et puis le
sioux cse cette biographie
de l'ancien prémunit ses doigts fini
publié aux éditions de l'archipel